l a tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fatti jv chiedo scusa
ragazzi se faccio la intro in fretta
perché cosa è successo allora stavo per
montare il blog di sabato quando
guardando tra le varie clip che avevo
del giappone mi è uscita fuori questa
clip che è bellissima dovete vederla
questa cosa cioè non ha senso non ha
senso eravamo in giappone con email
erano le due di notte ed eravamo appena
tornati a casa dopo l'altra japan e
siccome erano chiusi tutti i ristoranti
quindi non potevamo mangiare alle 2 di
notte fuori abbiamo deciso di comprare
del rame istantaneo ecco questo era lo
scenario è difficile da spiegare potete
solo vederla quindi buona visione
ma se l'aspetta e saper cucinare tolga
cucinare di cazzo sei multan cucinarli
inquadra soprattutto per cucinare
ragazzi come perché si rimanda sopra la
praticamente questo è successo siamo
tornati dall'ultra mesi festival a
mezzanotte ovviamente tutti gli isolanti
sono chiusi per la prima volta problema
a cucinare giapponese abbiamo questa
cosa cross di placement prodotti teoria
che saranno ma dovrebbe essere del rame
del rame del rame mai cucinato l'amen in
vita mia
lo zio ti ho detto scusa a cazzo compri
qualcosa che poi quel chi le legge le le
istruzioni qua le istituzioni sono molto
chiara perché tu sei votante quale
mutano la lingua dari ball casini di
spacchettamento macchietta mente dei
ragazzi è un box andrè maritano e le
posate qui non so anche cosa le mani
idrico cosa mangiano le bacchette metà
fighter cade il culo ma perché mica
questo la mensa raboni a
di cucina no è poi quello adesso perché
ormai era aperto la cosa che si
disegnare le fa la cucina eravamo in
sarebbe versare dell'acqua calda centro
la vaschetta quindi questa e dovrebbe
cuocere così così crazy male disk ad
alcuno stava illustrando s ecco c'è
qualcosa che non va ci sono cose c'è una
bustina
ma quali sono spezia questo lo so anche
io questa è un'altra specie all'acqua
mettila quella pasta venti deboli
ma allora ti metti dentro a toccare che
ci hai mai sport questa è la vasta e
finta aspetta per me la pasta delle
barre di che adesso menti l'acqua qua
dentro l'acqua ma decisi sì ma non me
non mentre la zia non mi bruciare zio
piano che deve inquadrare ma non è calda
0 vuoi provare romano non è caldo a
calais baba non poco poco palmas
basta ricopri e proprio l'acqua con
l'acqua prima copri come d'acqua ha co
prodotto
ok al supermoto adesso lascia un po così
nel frattempo aggiungiamo le robe le
robe le spezie ha attaccato poi abbiamo
uno con mangia i ris dovranno abbiamo
mangiato tutto il giorno e colom angeli
ma come fai a vivere se quella roba non
lo so
multa dai bingguo tale volontà del
votate ma papà sono divenuti partito ma
non devi farti domande butta dentro non
fuori bene con fuori dentro ma si jolo
poiché è perfetto mix che si è finto ma
butta dentro
minchia se cadeva sul mio computer
distacco a destra tutte e due le mani
stileremo stefani cosa avreste mai sto
cucinando io ti piace quello che faccio
no truck sarà buona alla fine non diro
cava sarà buono ma e butta tutto dentro
ma sappia no buttate in sabbia
dopo te lo giuro e sappia tutto questo
saranno presa l'arancione 9 sono presa
da amsterdam direttamente fumo ma dentro
comunque questo si mette la prima in là
quando lo volevo dire però che abbiamo
sbagliato le misure
oddio cos'è lo dà dentro questo è un
liquido e fragola no e soia soia sono
gli seminari che ha inquadrato re di
merda ci sta di tutto sulla tavola
ok adesso sai che si fa se aggiunge
acqua aggiunge ancora aggiunge aveva
riempire empi d'acqua e che è perché
colore che chuck bass e adesso adesso
devi girare o bollito no la camicia che
merda con le vacche e non ci sono le
bacchette
ma perché c'è il culo da fuori gira gira
gira dei vigili più zio dei vj di più
gira gira gira gira bene giro giro
minchia ho sentito torino l'ho sentito
torino tali sbocco di tanto come la vedi
tu devi far finta che sia la cosa più
bella tali da evitare che diventerà la
cosa più malato vita di più ci dirà chi
ha capito un attimo gira gira gira gira
in tutto il gioco perché guardato il
como ha detto incontrando il tuo bene
vai ebbe un nuovo tipo di e compagni cgg
nando famoso in moravia sociale
associato assaggio nel lavandino perché
ho paura che so che lei è jason ferrari
a signa ne sono la prova assaggio in
questo punto nel lavandino poi perché
potrei sboccata e romy spunti sulla bara
così schifo no no no se andrebbero non è
buona alla fine tutto ciò che vedi non è
verità capita di tipo matrix pensa che
ci sia qualcuno di tre reti che sta
dicendo che vuol com'è
min chiamate si dice che buono come e
crudo e buono
mio nonno ci siamo meglio da 1 a 10
minchia alloggi non altro po
va bene a loro e mi fai la pubblicità
mangia teheran ramin di farisei buono
qui buono qui se così fosse qui non è
buona
l'omaggio a di host ragazzo deve
mangiare lo capite
l'ho capita il disagio mio quando io
riguardo le clip del giappone cerco di
trovare qualcosa che vada bene per un
video lo capite il mio disagio nel
vedere certa roba non potevo non metter
vela come video ci abbiate pazienza dei
ragazzi è stato uno dei video più belli
che abbia mai fatto nella mia più
intelligenti soprattutto che poi è
uscito in sei minuti lo abbiamo fatto a
cazzo
a 100.000 like faccio cucina italiana
che non è tanto meglio è per come la
cucino io quindi regazzoli spero mi sia
piaciuto cose mi è piaciuto sotto il
momento è un mi piace alla pagina di
facebook come nei video stata una
descrizione se lo sapessi ti scateni
civile diavolo proseguito e ragazzi